une journée mondiale du nettoyage de la
planète le World clean update c'est
notamment ce samedi à 16 septembre ils
pourront parler avec nous Annie roseba
bonjour bonjour vous êtes responsable de
l'association ini Montaine je respecte
ma ville et vous organisez notamment le
rendez-vous sur la commune de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux est-ce que déjà
vous pouvez nous rappeler l'importance
de ce walking update oui alors ce qu'il
faut que je dise ce n'est pas que ce
samedi ça commence aujourd'hui et c'est
jusqu'à dimanche en fonction des
décalages horaires parce que c'est un
mouvement planétaire c'est un grand défi
mondial de nettoyage de la planète à nos
jours donc il y en a qui commence
aujourd'hui notamment les entreprises
certaines écoles et puis à travers le
monde en fonction des fuseaux horaires
bah avant s'est déployé les cleaners à
travers la planète pour ramasser le
maximum de déchets alors en 2022 en
France c'est 170000 personnes qui se
sont mobilisées ça rassemble où il faut
encore aller chercher les gens de plus
en plus alors est-ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que on observe une migration des
citoyens des comportements c'est à dire
que ce qui jetait deviennent de vrais
cleaner donc ça veut dire que le message
est entendu et que à force de montrer
l'exemple et bah ça sensibilise vraiment
et on a de plus en plus de personnes
convaincues de plus en plus de personnes
mais aussi un nombre qui augmente chaque
année c'est la quantité de déchets
ramassés c'est très marquant la quantité
ça dépend des communes ça dépend des
sites envoie-moi des déchets quand même
parce que s'il y a de plus en plus les
gens qui ramassent ça veut dire qu'il y
a de moins de moins en moins de
pollueurs voilà l'idée quand même c'est
de se dire que à terme on devra se poser
la question de est-ce qu'on continue
parce que il y aura de moins en moins
des déchets
actuellement le déchet le plus marquant
moi j'en ai même à mes pieds c'est le
mégot de cigarettes on en trouve partout
partout et notamment dans les
hypersentres parce qu'il y a des bureaux
et parce qu'il y a aussi beaucoup plus
de personnes voilà qui sont dans un
moment de loisirs donc il fume et qui
malheureusement jettent dans mes goûts
pas au bon endroit alors ça mobilise du
monde on l'a dit juste avant tout le
monde peut y participer tout âge c'est
une activité
intergénérationnelle je parlais tout à
l'heure des enfants qui ont commencé le
mercredi au Seigneur alors je parlais de
la ville de Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est
ce samedi 16 septembre la nature qui
vient il y a 9 points de rendez-vous
qu'est-ce que ça signifie ça veut dire
qu'on embarque tous les tous les
quartiers tous les habitants de la ville
parce qu'on a envie que notre ville
reste propre et c'est la cinquième
édition avec la ville et la sixième avec
l'association ça va se passer comment
vous dites en embarque après tout le
monde se balade parce que c'est la
cinquième fois qu'on le fait et il y a
toujours beaucoup de succès il 9 points
de dès le départ dont un à l'île de
loisirs c'est le 8e en fait on a un
double point là sur le riz qui a un
grand quartier d'où le double point et
puis le point qu'on a rajouté c'est la
porte de la digue à la derrière le
vélodrome ce sont des points marquants
de la vie de rassemblement c'est des
points visuels où les gens se retrouvent
plus facilement vous attendez combien de
personnes bah écoutez
comment plus ça tombe souvent le
week-end des journées mondiales des
journées pendant des journées du
patrimoine une grosse concurrence sur
sur le World update mais bon on espère
qu'on aura beaucoup plus de clients je
n'ai pas vraiment de de chiffres à vous
dire
ramasser des déchets ça peut inquiéter
aussi on peut parfois tomber sur des
choses un peu dangereuses à ce qu'il y a
une tenue à prendre absolument il faut
pas venir un talon aiguille bien entendu
ni en boca c'est un pompon ce qu'il
faudra c'est des baskets adaptées un
jean et surtout et surtout des gants et
je précise bien des gants avec embout
voilà pour qu'il n'y ait pas de tes sons
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de descendre
bouteille pour qu'il y ait pas de
d'épines ou des choses ou des choses qui
piquent d'ailleurs je suis très fière de
celle-là c'est les
vous avez aussi dans la main très
important et voilà c'est une pince parce
qu'il y a des personnes malheureusement
qui voilà ne peuvent pas se baisser pour
diverses raisons et qui voilà et puis il
y a des déchets qui sont dans les
buissons qu'on ne peut pas forcément
aller chercher très très loin donc il
faut quand même une pince pour aller
tracter voilà ce qui entre les buissons
ça fait cinq ans que vous êtes avec la
commune de Montigny avec la ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
il faut savoir c'est que l'association
je respecte ma vie et une association
éco-citoyenne qui est sensible au
respect du cadre de vie donc il dit
cadre de vie qui dit beauté ça veut dire
que tout ce qui n'est pas à sa place en
terme de déchets nuit au Bien Vivre
Ensemble donc du coup on cherchait quand
on a créé l'association une activité
qui mettrait les citoyens face à leur
reste délicat donc du coup on a eu
connaissance donc du working Dead et on
s'est dit bah tiens ça ça correspond
tout à fait aux activités qu'on a envie
de faire dans l'association et c'est
comme ça que la première édition elle a
d'abord fait toute seule enfin seule
avec des membres de l'association dans
un quartier et comme ça avait eu
relativement du succès et qu'on avait eu
la demande pour l'année d'après on s'est
dit pourquoi il ferait pas dans toute la
ville et comme ça il y aurait plusieurs
points exactement merci Annie rosema
nous avoir accordé cet entretien alors
pour découvrir les différents
rendez-vous proposé par les communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines n'hésitez pas
à vous rendre sur leur site internet
mais aussi celui de l'agglomération qui
recense tous les points de rendez-vous à
noter que des communes comme morpa et
voisin de Bretonneux leur rendez-vous
eux c'est le 17 septembre c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve sur notre site
Internet et nos réseaux sociaux belle
soirée sur TV 78